I didn't know sales as a term existed
the first time somebody walked in he's
like oh go sign this girl up no training
no script no nothing I came from a
management consulting background I had
no idea what I was doing I was like
Jim's 129 a month when I signed up and
she was like yeah I don't have my credit
card with me I just have to go get it I
was like okay then I walked out two
minutes later and I was like yeah she's
gonna sign up he was like you closed her
in two minutes and I was like yeah I
guess he's like you got the card and I
was like no but she's she'll be back
she's just gonna go get a credit card
he's like ah dude if you don't get the
card you didn't call us